es war ein mythos für die kids werfen
der mutprobe nachts in den wald zu gehen
ich bin persönlich überhaupt kein kenner
des horrorfilms und bin auch niemand der
horror filme per se interessant findet
nicht weil ich irgendwie angst zu große
angst habe aber hier geht es immer mehr
um die dramatischen psychologischen
tendenzen und befinden sich sehr häufig
einfach immer um schockmomente und das
finde ich eigentlich relativ schnell
langweilig und das ist eigentlich das
was ich am besten an den film finde das
sehr sehr präzise sehr konzentriert wie
so genau
stöße den schrecken macht es ist nicht
so von anfang bis ende nur schrecken
sondern es ist sehr genau ich würde fast
sagen komponiert ist auf jeden fall
nicht posten
er beginnt wie so ein realistischer
familienfilm so amerikanischer
familienfest sie haben und sogar einen
ganzen wald als garten dazu gegeben und
dann gibt es diese kippmomente die da
reinkommen und dann nur das ist wieder
etwas es ist es ist viel raffinierter
als früher wo man bei so horrorfilm
schon viel schneller das genre erkannt
hat hier wird das genre eigentlich wieso
zurückgehalten und nur in ganz präzisen
einzelnen momenten kommt es ganz durch
alley hat heute im wald einen ganz
besonderen ort entdeckt
den friedhof der kuscheltiere
dort kann man haustiere beerdigen und um
sie trauern das muss ich aber keine
angst machen
es ist völlig natürlich genauso
natürlich wieder die ganze stadt nutzt
diesen ort schon seit generationen für
die kinder hier ist es eine art ritual
geworden irgendetwas stimmt mit diesem
boden mit diesem ort nicht das wird
relativ schnell klar diese weit
gehörte etwas andere nachdem das
haustier stirbt nimmt der nachbar den
familienvater beiseite und sagt wir
müssen den begraben an einer ganz
bestimmten stelle und am nächsten tag
ist die katze auf einmal wieder da gibt
einen zentralen satz darin wo sich das
ehepaar eben unterhält sagen wir jetzt
dem kind die katze ist gestorben oder
sagen wir die katze ist einfach
weggelaufen
was ist los es geht um tripp vermuten
wir dass george weggelaufen ist
er ist ich weggelaufen er ist letzte
nacht von meinem fenster gewesen dass so
ausgangs covidien der filmen das sehr
ernst und sagt eben mehr oder weniger
eigentlich von da aus erzählt er die
ganze geschichte der mensch sollte sich
nicht zu sicher sein
die kasse wird was eigentlich nach dem
tod passiert ich weiß was sie vorhaben
aber sie kommen nicht so zurück wie sie
waren
war es wirklich gut mal ein remake zu
machen also das was nicht der status quo
der verfilmung ist dieser verfilmung in
den 80er jahren nicht das ist hier schon
einfache state of the art und es gibt
eine ganz bestimmte professionalität die
nicht irgendwie nur bling bling und
glänzend ist sondern die einfach ernst
nimmt die unterschiedlichen ebenen in
dem stoff und die eben versucht das mit
neuester kamera und dramaturgie technik
zu erzählen ich würde eben nur als
einzige kritikpunkt sagen die
schauspielkunst eigentlich müsste man
ernster nehmen und man müsste diesen
figuren die dort angelegt sind das ist
nämlich auch nicht einfach nur
schablonen und sind symbolhafte figuren
sie haben ein eigenleben und die müsste
man noch besser schauspielerisch
ausarbeiten und das den fokus darauf
legen dass ist
aber machen mit seiner tochter in den
nächsten jahren sind 28 verfilmung von
stephen king geplant ist ein irrsinniger
boom
warum bei stephen king ist eben es
interessanter deswegen eigens für solche
verfügungen eben auch das ist immer die
verschiedenen eben sind immer doppelt
würdige ebenen es gibt eben den klaren
plot geschichte wo man jeder sofort auch
irgendwie darauf einsteigen kann der
grusel aber dann gibt es eben eine
unterirdische und zweite ebene die in
diesem falle eben das archaische berührt
also frage nach leben gibt es so etwas
wie ein leben nach dem tod paradies und
hölle
also sieben ging es einfach komplexer
als einfach nur einen schotterstreifen
und deswegen wird er ebenso viel auch
was wäre würde ich sagen
und gerade in unserer zeit der
ambivalenzen die interessiert sind an
doppelbödigkeit an unterschiedlichen eco
notationen nicht am nicht an einen
deutlichkeit uneindeutigkeit dann hat er
jetzt eben eine renaissance erhalten und
der der film macht eigentlich das jetzt
was in den büchern angelegt ist versucht
der film jetzt ernst zu nehmen und in
bilder zu gießen
das habe ich da oben in den bäumen
gesagt ja das sind warnungen die
indianer haben sie vor ihrer flucht dort
eingesetzt ihre flucht sie wussten was
für eine macht dieser ort besaß sie
führten seine anziehungskraft
sie glaubten dass diese wald zu etwas
anderem gehört erstmal sollte man zu
zweit in diesem film gehen es gibt ein
paar wirklich sehen wie kommen sie
vergisst man auch nicht so schnell dass
man durchaus hin und wieder die augen
schließt und da ist es natürlich
grundsätzlich angenommen hat einen
anderen arm den man greifen kann
währenddessen also deswegen würde ich
raten zu zweiter hineinzugehen
ich würde schon sagen das ist nicht nur
ein film für die addex für die kenner
für die für die genre fanatiker des
horrorfilms ja es ist schon ein film der
sich an ein breiteres publikum verwendet
und in dieser form kann ich schon
empfehlen
neben der ein interesse daran hat zu
schauen wie man sich heute im 21
jahrhundert mit den alten ingredienzien
vollmond wald auferstehung friedhof das
sind ja alles traditionellen
ingredienzien des horrorgenres aber wie
macht man das heute im 21 jahrhundert so
dass man davon eben
von vorne bis hinten mit gezogen wird
und nicht sagt gern gern habe ich schon
15 mal gesehen sodass sich das durchaus
schon empfehlen kann
[Applaus]